hey everyone and welcome to what was
that with gabe sanchez the fbi seized my
pillow ceo mike lindell's phone while he
was ordering at a hardy's drive-through
i wish i was joking but that's uh that's
literally what happened
[Music]
before i start i just want to point out
what i think might be the funniest and
dumbest thing that mike lindell did
after getting his phone seized he shared
the search warrant on his show but also
accidentally shared the last four digits
of his social security number lucky for
him no one wants to steal this trump's
ticket fans identity so when trump heard
the news of lindel's phone being seized
he went straight to truth social trump
said that the pillow guy mike lindell
was raided we live in a weaponized
police state and we have rigged
elections there's a couple problems with
that narrative for starters it's hard
for mike lindell to be raided when he
was literally standing outside in a
drive-through i mean what was the fbi
going to raid the air around him also
mike lindell handed his phone to the fbi
after being instructed to do so by an
attorney then i got the lawyer yelling
on the phone just give him the phone
give him the phone though the jury's
still loud if he called trump's tv
lawyer jim trustee oh and one more thing
i want to point out republicans are the
ones trying to weaponize law enforcement
at polling locations in order to rig
elections in their favor anyway back to
mike lindell let's hear him tell the
story and we go through a hardy's
drive-through
we pull around the back and we're just
about going through we pulled through
the drive-through to take the order we
pull up and she says pull ahead
you know because they had to make the
order part of it wasn't done thank you
for explaining how a drive-through works
and a car comes perpendicular and parks
like a little ways in front of us
tonight and i've been around the block
and i said to my buddy i said
um that's either a bad guy
or it's uh it's fbi i i said that
straight up honestly i was hoping the
fbi would seize his phone while he
wasn't wearing pants you know kind of
like with jeffrey clark or that time
lindell was live streaming in a hotel
courtyard back in 2021. don't don't let
the liptarts kill your names don't let
them call you an ethically dubious
pillow pusher
don't let them call you a a marginally
uh brain-addled uh corrupt goofball
and somehow mike lindell is unable to
understand how this could happen i can't
even imagine you can just take
somebody's phone
because they want me to be a witness in
in a in
um the tina peters uh case sorry mike
but the fbi can seize your phone because
you know what they have probable cause
that a crime was committed the search
was a legally authorized grand jury
subpoena that was signed off by a
federal judge you think by now after
seeing all these other trump associates
get their phone seized and their home
search that they would at least
understand why this is happening to them
and the reason they served mike
lindell's search warrant was for the
contents of his phone as part of an
investigation into a colorado election
security breach according to the warrant
the probe is looking into conduct
involving tina peters coney james hayes
belinda nicely sandra brown sharona
bishop michael lindell and or douglas
frank among other co-conspirators known
and unknown to the government in may of
2021 tina peters and her stop the steel
posse allegedly orchestrated a plan that
involved conan james hayes pretending to
be a tech worker in order to illegally
copy mesa county voting machine data and
it should come as no surprise that hayes
is a conspiracy theorist with ties to
mike lindell douglas frank reportedly
passed along the information about the
scheme to lindell who had already been
spreading election lies about dominion
voting machines and i just want to
remind you that dominion is suing mike
lindell for defamation shirona bishop is
an associate of lindell and peters who
participated in their election denier
rallies she's also the former campaign
manager of representative lauren bobert
and unsurprisingly in 2019 bishop
praised the far-right neo-fascist group
the proud boys so in an effort to prove
the 2020 election had been rigged
against donald trump peters made copies
of sensitive information from the
dominion voting machines which then
found its way online and was spread
around the election denier community so
let's fast forward to august 2021 where
tina peters is attending mike lindell's
cyber symposium and while she's there a
search warrant is executed on her office
i got an order from the secretary of
state that she was going to invade my
elections department today and guess
what when i was on a plane to come see
you kind folks and to talk to you out
there guess what they did
they provided a search warrant and
raided my office
we don't know what they were doing in
there no we do see peters broke the law
by leaking the voting machine data and
they traced it right back to her office
and then later on q and on influencer
ron watkins virtually attended the
symposium and said this we have a
problem
my lawyer my lord just called me ty
clevenger mr tychovinder
and he said
uh that i should put out this statement
and
i just learned that conan james hayes
may have taken without authorization
the actual hard drives from the mesa
county or the mesa
colorado county clerk
and he needs to produce those hard
drives immediately and return them to
the clerk wait what was that and he
needs to produce those hard drives
immediately and return them to the clerk
somehow the guy pushing far right q9
conspiracy theories is the only one
making sense right now wow that feels
really weird to say and then in november
of 2021 the fbi searched four colorado
locations two of which were tina peters
and sharona bishop's homes and now
peters has been charged with three
misdemeanors and seven felonies
including conspiracy to commit criminal
impersonation and identity theft look
i'm no lawyer but if you are facing 10
criminal charges i would suggest that
you find yourself a safe house or a
relative close by lay low for a while
however peters has done the complete
opposite just this past june peters told
the new york times that representative
lauren bobert had encouraged her to go
forward with the imaging of the voting
machine data now lauren bobert denies
telling peters this but considering
bobert's history and her connection to
sharona bishop i wouldn't be surprised
if peter's claim was true i'm fairly
certain that more details will come out
before peter's trial on march 6 2023
which honestly should be an open and
shut case and speaking of cases the
justice department has ramped up its
investigation of attempts by trump's
allies to overturn the 2020 election
they've issued more than 40 subpoenas
with a broad reach one of the many
subjects the subpoenas are seeking
information about is evidence tending to
show that there was fraud of any kind in
or relating to the 2020 presidential
election so now the republicans who have
been falsely accusing democrats of
committing election fraud are actually
the ones being investigated by the doj
for committing election fraud and
remember folks every republican's
accusation is a confession well i'm gabe
sanchez and this has been what was that
[Music]